In the last twenty years, one approach to treating Autism has been far superior
to other forms and has much empirical support. This approach follows ABA
principals, and this specific technique was pioneered by Ivar Lovaas. And is
termed Early Intensive Behavioral Intervention, or EIBI. It's termed Early,
because the children with autism begin treatment very early in their lives,
some as young as 18 months. It's termed Intensive, because it requires 20 to 40
hours of therapy per week. EIBI has been shown to improve adaptive behavior,
expressive language, receptive language and daily communication skills.
Moreover, it improves daily living skills, and some studies have shown
increases in IQ. Therapist use the principles of ABA to teach children with
Autism Spectrum Disorders verbal behavior and communication skills. They also
teach these children how to play, as this is a skill that they often lack. This
evidence based therapy using ABA was recently the subject of the California
senate. When they unanimously passed an extension to an autism law that
requires insurance companies to cover ABA therapies for treating ASD. And they
did so, because these therapies are effective.